Hello world.
It's a Raj and let's see if we can teach
an AI car how to drive to the top of a
mountain using a super popular
strategy called Q learning.
Since Video Games are
considered virtual worlds,
we'll want to use reinforcement learning
to help our AI learn how to best
interact with its environment.
That means using time delayed labels,
Aka rewards to help it learn how best
to act in the environment through trial
and error to complete its objective.
If an AI has a model of all the
necessary elements of its environment,
meaning the states rewards,
transition model, et cetera.
Basically everything that makes
up a mark Haub decision process,
it can easily then use a
planning algorithm to compute
a solution to whatever
its objective is. So easy. A
liberal arts major could do it.
This is considered model based learning.
An Ai will interact in the environment
and from the history of its interactions.
The AI will try to approximate the
environments models afterwards.
Given the models it's learned.
The AI can use the value iteration or
policy iteration algorithms to find an
optimal policy,
but our agent doesn't necessarily have
to try and learn an explicit model for
its environment.
It can also derive an optimal policy
directly from its interactions with the
environment without building a model,
and this is called model
free learning model.
Free learning involves predicting the
value function of a certain policy without
having a concrete model
of the environment.
The simplest way to do this is
using the Manet Carlo technique,
meaning using repeated random
sampling to obtain numerical results.
But this only works on episodic tasks
where you have a certain set of actions.
Then the episode ends with
some total reward money.
Carlo learning states that the return of
estate is just the mean average of the
total reward from when a
state appeared onwards.
So in order to reduce the variance, we
can use a different method of prediction.
Temporal difference learning updates
the values of each state based on a
prediction of the final return.
For example,
let's say Monte Carlo learning takes a
hundred actions and then updates them all
based on the final return.
Td learning would take an action and
then update the value of the previous
action based on the value
of the current action.
Td Learning has the advantage of updating
values on more recent trends in order
to capture more of the
effect of a certain state.
Td has a lower variance than Monte Carlo
as each update depends on less factors.
However,
Monte Carlo has no bias as values are
updated directly towards the final return.
While TD has some bias, as values
are updated towards a prediction,
both TD and Monte Carlo or actually
opposite ends of a spectrum between full
look ahead and one step look ahead,
any number of steps can be taken before
passing the return back to an action.
So a question arises.
How many steps is optimal to look ahead?
Well,
it varies greatly depending
on the environment and it's
often a hardcoded hyper
parameter.
Td learning can be used to learn both
the value function and the Q function.
What's that? You said, does Q stand
for quick time? No, thankfully.
If we want our AI to always choose an
action that maximizes the discounted
future reward,
we'd want to use some form of TD learning.
We could define a function cue that
represents the maximum discounted future
award when we perform an action a in
state s and continue optimally from that
point on.
The way to think about this function is
that it's the best possible score at the
end of the game.
After performing an action a in a state
s it's called the Q function because it
represents the quality of a certain
action in a given state. Using it,
we can estimate the score at the end of
the game knowing just the current state
and action and not knowing actions
and rewards coming after that.
So suppose we're in a state and deciding
whether we should take action a or B,
we want to select the action that results
in the highest score at the end of the
game.
Once we have the magical Q function,
the answer becomes really simple.
We can just pick the action
with the highest Q value.
So we need to learn this Q function and
we can call this process cue learning.
We can express the Q value of state s
and action a in terms of the Q value of
the next state s. This is called the
bellman equation. If you think about it,
it makes sense.
Maximum future award for
the state inaction is the
immediate reward plus maximum
future reward for the next state.
The main idea in cue learning is that
we can iteratively approximate the Q
function using the bellman equation.
In the simplest case,
the Q function is implemented as a
table with states as rows and actions as
columns. So to start the Q
table is initialized randomly.
Then the agent starts to interact with
the environment and upon each interaction
the agent will observe the reward of
its action and the state transition.
The agent computes the observed Q value
and then updates its own estimate of
cute.
So we've got a basic iteration going
and it works for simple policies.
However, there's a problem, it's
not exploring like Hernand Cortez.
Shout out to AP history.
Let's say we're at a state with two doors,
one door,
it gives a reward of plus one every time
and the other door gives zero reward,
but has a 10% chance of giving
a 100 reward on the first run.
The second door doesn't get lucky
and returns a reward of zero.
Since it's acting greedily,
the Ai will only ever take the first
doors since the considers it the better
option.
So how do we fix this random exploration?
At some probability,
the program,
we'll take a random action instead
of taking the optimal action.
This allows it to eventually figure out
that there is some extremely high reward
hidden behind the second door
if he tries it out. However,
we want the AI to eventually converge at
some optimal policy so we can lower the
probability of taking a random action
over time as the agent becomes more
confident with its estimate of Q values.
So using Q learning and
open Ai's gym environment,
we can teach a mountain car how
to successfully climb a mountain.
In this environment.
There is a car on a one dimensional
track between two mountains.
The goal of the car is to climb
the mountain on its right. However,
the engine is not strong enough to climb
mountains without having to go back to
gain some momentum by climbing
the mountain on the left here,
the agent is the car and
possible actions are drive left,
do nothing or drive
right at every time step,
the agent receives a penalty of minus one
which means that the goal of the agent
is the climb the right mountain as
fast as possible to minimize the sum of
negative one penalties it receives.
The observation is two
continuous variables
representing the velocity and the
position of the car.
Since the observation variables
are continuous for our algorithm,
we desk or ties the observed
values in order to use Q learning.
Initially the car will take forever
to climb if we select a random action,
but after learning,
it learns how to climb the mountain
within less than a hundred times steps.
You're still with me, right? Of course
you are. You beautiful wizard. Look,
there are just three key
points to remember here. Model.
Free learning is when an AI can directly
derive an optimal policy from its
interactions with the environment without
needing to create a model beforehand.
Cue learning is a model free learning
technique that can be used to find the
optimal action selection policy using
a Q function and the exploration versus
exploitation dilemma is exemplified by
the question of whether an AI should
trust the learnt values of Q enough to
select actions based on it or try other
actions hoping that might
give it a better reward.
The winner of last week's coding
challenge is odd. Nones a heat.
I'd non created an AI in swift that
navigates around a grid to find the goal
without knowing it beforehand.
Then it constructs an optimal path to
the goal using model free reinforcement
learning,
superb job and shout out to Alberto
Garces for creating a really awesome value
iteration algorithm for getting a taxi
from point a to point B efficiently.
This week's challenge is to
create a simple cue learning
algorithm in python for
an AI in any type of game world. Get
humbling scope in the comments section,
and I will personally review and
announce the top two entries next Friday.
Please subscribe for
more programming videos,
and now I've got approximately my
value function, so thanks for watching.